E aí
[Música]
em todo lado é um ato político e é por
isso que o maior erro que podemos
cometer é o diário política porque ela é
o que somos e como vivemos na verdade o
que a gente precisa fazer é redesenha
aula quando era criança assim como toda
e qualquer criança que começa a
desbravar o mundo interpretar eu me
perguntava por que de tantas pessoas
estarem na rua o porquê de tanta fome no
mundo mas eu nunca tive respostas
concretas e simples para essas perguntas
é só que a cada vez que eu me perguntava
e pedir explicações para esses problemas
que observava eu percebi que eu também
começava a me movimentar de alguma forma
Oi e a cada por que que eu me
questionava
e eu eu percebi aqui aquilo podia me dar
justificativas reais aqueles problemas
que eu comecei a observar no mundo
e é por isso que eu sonho com o dia em
que as pessoas vão fazendo porque a
ferramenta mais poderosa para fazer as
transformações que nós queremos ver no
mundo
e com sete anos eu comecei a jogar
futsal e era uma grande paixão fiz
escolinha de Futsal e jogava na escola
também era eu uma amiga em vários
meninos
e nesse meio é os melhores Recreios que
eu tinha eram os Recreios em que eu
podia jogar bola tranquilamente com os
meninos que eles me permitiram fazer
parte disso os melhores dias na escola
eram os dias em que eu não é o via
aqueles aquelas crianças né os meus
colegas comentaram uns com os outros
Nossa vai perder para uma menina que
vergonha porque eu gostava muito de
jogar bola e aquilo era muito importante
para mim mas ao mesmo tempo eu me
machucava e eu ficava triste só que eu
não consegui entender o porquê nós
meninas Nunca Estamos incluídos nos
jogos
há 11 anos eu passei no concurso do
colégio militar do exército e com 12 eu
já era questionada sobre as roupas que
eu vestia
e às vezes curta demais às vezes
Aparecida demais e jun tava isso com o
meu jeito super comunicativo e
extrovertido
bom e se tornou um motivo do suficientes
para que eu fosse questionada sobre ser
a menina fácil demais principalmente
para os meninos mais velhos
e também um pouco briguenta e isso era
uma reação minha as dores que eu estava
sentindo naquele momento de não ter de
não me sentir incluída e de questionar
minha própria capacidade e a minha
própria dignidade
e eu não consegui entender Por que que
um colégio intelectualmente respeitado
como aquele e aquele é uma pessoa como
eu isso porque eu me sentia impura
indigna de frequentar aquele ambiente
bom Essas foram as primeiras vezes da
minha vida em que um problema estrutural
se manifestavam mas eu ainda não
conseguia perceber isso
é o que eu consegui começar a perceber
foi que as minhas vivências enquanto
mulher na sociedade que a gente vive
hoje ela sempre seriam restritas
é E essas foram as primeiras situações
marcantes mesmo da minha vida
bom então lembra de ter vivenciado a
crueldade de uma sociedade machista
e eu entendi que as operações de gênero
elas se manifestam diversas esferas da
nossa vida
bom e é muito por isso que quando saímos
na rua e somos assediados por uma subiu
Inconveniente ou os salários desiguais
em relação aos homens que ocupam o mesmo
cargo e até índices altíssimos de
feminicídio principalmente na América
Latina sempre assustam elas fazem parte
da nossa realidade
Oi e o grande o grande avanço do
movimento feminista no Brasil já
aconteceu também
e conquistamos o direito ao sufrágio
Universal em 1932 mulheres e homens são
vistos juridicamente como iguais pela
Constituição de 1988
Ah mas isso ainda é muito pouco
e a gente precisa de uma luta intensa
uma luta em que nós todas participamos
ela
Ah e não só isso mas o papel assinado
ele não é suficiente para garantir que
nós tenhamos a nossa liberdade
é porque a história nos mostra que a
marca a marca das operações da violência
até hoje afeta a comunidade das mulheres
E aí depois que eu entendi que essa luta
essa dor não era só minha era uma dor
coletiva era mudou compartilhado por
todas as mulheres eu decidi também que
eu dedicaria o meu tempo para que nem
uma outra menina se sentisse encapar vou
questionar sua própria dignidade como eu
a vi esperimentado com 12 anos de idade
Ah e assim eu passei a se você tá tão
bem a escuta eu passei a começar a
escutar as pessoas e as vivências que eu
não tinha aos poucos entende que a minha
vivência com mulher branca não é a mesma
da mulher preta e não é a mesma da
mulher trança
e não é a mesma da mulher periférica
Oi e a gente não precisa ter culpa dos
privilégios que nós temos
e o que nós não podemos fazer é deixar
de reconhecer os porque quando a gente
reconhece eles a gente começa a avançar
o e somente quando todas nós estivermos
incluídas nesse debate é que a gente vai
poder caminhar junta é por isso que
todas as vezes que falamos sobre
igualdade de gênero a gente tá falando
necessariamente sobre uma luta que a
coletiva pela emancipação de todas nós
e em todas as nossas diferenças
e no colégio e eu não Colégio Militar
sempre me chamavam de Rebelde era algo
que me machucava um pouco mas com o
tempo eu também fui entendendo que
Rebelde talvez pudesse significar alguma
coisa boa
a 2019 eu me tornei presidente da
agremiação estudantil
bom e que é uma organização muito
importante para os alunos do colégio
e depois de um ano inteiro de trabalho
nas vésperas do meu discurso final no
meu discurso de encerramento eu eu tava
lendo um livro deitada na minha cama no
dia anterior né e e tinha uma nota de
rodapé me chamou muito a minha atenção
estava escrito Rebelde é aquele que não
se conformam
e no dia seguinte eu iniciei meu
discurso na frente dos meus pais dos
meus amigos e de várias militares
completamente fora do script e eu já
tinha entregue aquele script
um por um motivo muito importante fazer
política
e a partir daquele momento eu comecei a
falar fazer uma discurso dizendo que eu
concordava pela primeira vez com todas
as pessoas que já me chamaram de Rebelde
alguma vez na vida porque eu entendi que
Rebelde é quem faz o movimento e quem
não e a quem não se conforma e eu não
conseguia olhar para o painel de
ex-presidentes que estava na minha
frente naquele momento sendo inaugurado
com meu rosto e não perceber que no meio
de 30 pessoas quatro eram mulheres uma
era mulher negra eu ainda lembrava da
Sofia de 12 anos e eu sentia um pouco de
angústia eu não queria que nenhuma outra
menina de 12 anos tivesse sentir esse
questionar a própria dignidade
e de fato eu não consegui me conformar
com aquilo
eu e mais do que isso
e eu entendi a partir desse momento que
os meus atos eram atos políticos
bom e que eles eram necessários caso eu
quisesse começar a investir a lógica de
um sistema que nos Coloca embaixo do
tapete há tanto tempo
é desse discurso são eu comecei a
perceber algumas pessoas ficaram
incomodados com a minha fala
é porque feminismo direito das mulheres
e minorias sociais não são palavras que
são sempre bem aceitas na sociedade
é só que na verdade o que eu pude
perceber com microfone na mão é que uma
mulher quando ela tem voz e ela denuncia
as injustiças sociais e ocupa espaços
que não são comuns ela tava dançando
é esse o patriarcado fez com que nos
conformarmos Eu torço muito para que nos
rebelamos porque só assim a gente vai
poder redesenhar e reconstruir uma
sociedade em que nós sejamos vistos
respeitados e realmente interpretadas
com liberdade e com justiça social não
só no papel
e depois dessa Minha experiência pessoal
e comecei a pesquisar sobre política
institucional
eu comecei a perceber sobre as
lideranças que nós temos um no mundo os
políticos que nós colocamos para nos
representar e nessa minha busca eu
descobri que cinquenta e dois por cento
do eleitorado brasileiro é composto por
mulheres
é mas só quinze por cento da câmara do
deputados são mulheres de todos os
governadores dos estados do Brasil só
uma mulher
e isso me entregou
é só que eu entendi que a mesma lógica
que fez com que eu sentisse as dores AOS
7 e aos 12 anos era a lógica que também
explicava esse problema porque o mundo
construído até hoje não foi o mundo
construído para emancipação e
participação de mulheres e nem de seus
corpos
E no meio de seu descobrimento ainda
existia uma outra esfera que era esfera
familiar que julgava a política como
algo sujo ruim e completamente
indiscutível
e inclusive o desafio vocês a me
inscrever em um político
e eu aposto que ele é um homem branco
velho de terno rico e provavelmente
envolvido em corrupção
e com certeza tem muitos desses por aí
é mas como experiência eu entendi que se
nós nos reconhecemos como uma força
política a gente consegue construir um
novo Imaginário social
e o que nós precisamos fazer é nos
movimentar
Ah e assim como toda coisa grande ela
precisou de um primeiro movimento para
começar
e quando uma mulher entra na política
ela puxa outras
e quando uma mulher negra entra na
política Ela carrega consigo a
possibilidade de redesenhar aquele
espaço
e quando uma mulher da comunidade LGBT
que ia mais entra na política
e a gente começa a conversar sobre esse
assunto e ela carrega consigo a luta por
menos violência e intolerância
a representatividade simbólica é muito
importante porque ela nos permite criar
possibilidades que a estrutura social
desenhada até hoje por homens e brancos
e ela Ela nos permite que essas que essa
que essa estrutura ela seja re desenhada
é imaginada são novas possibilidades que
estão sendo criadas com novos rostos
colocados amigos e novas vivências
também
e quando a gente cria a possibilidade
dessas minorias ocupar esses espaços a
gente pode começar a disputar
consciências e a desenhar um novo
Imaginário social
é praticamente quando colocamos mais
mulheres na política a gente consegue
aprovar cerca de 3,5 vezes mais projetos
voltados para áreas sociais como
educação e saúde quando a gente coloca
mais diversidade na política a gente
cria possibilidades para a gente poder
começar a conversar de verdade sobre uma
democracia e é por isso que eu retorno a
minha fala do início
é porque numa pergunta é sempre um
primeiro movimento
e foi isso porque que me fez despertar
Aos sete anos numa quadra de futsal
e foi esse mesmo porque que me fez
despertar aos 12 quando era questionado
sobre as roupas que vestia e questionava
também a minha dignidade
bom e é isso mesmo porque que me
movimento tem me desperta todos os dias
é a questão toda é que no mundo
construído por homens brancos e ricos
quando a gente ocupa esses passos a
gente incomoda que a gente a bala uma
estrutura social inteira mas a gente
também mostra que uma sociedade diversa
plural diferente e nova pode ser
construída porque nós somos múltiplos
diferentes e grandes
Oi e aí eu quero te perguntar
se você já sabe por que é importante
colocarmos mais mulheres e mais
diversidade na política em todos os
outros espaços
bom obrigado